[Musique]
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réaction
vous êtes blessé
indignez vous touchez à la fin peinée et
vexée parce que je me dis f que 20 en
bout de tant d'années quelqu'un qui a
vécu quand même près de moi étaient des
rats à des réactions petites comme ça
elle considère que vous êtes mal
entourée elle pense qu'il ya une
machination contre que amis même moi
j'avais quand même des années que je
m'occupe de ma et non mon chemin et plus
de moyens de bord enfin il existe
est ce que finalement le fait de refuser
les expertises médicales n'est pas un
mauvais calcul
je veux bien avoir une expertise
médicale mais je ne veux pas qu'elle me
l'influencent ma vie c'est ma vie
[Musique]